vous êtes non Thaïlande vous avez été
adopté à l'âge d'un an et trois mois
vous avez grandi dans le Loir-et-Cher
vous avez commencé le théâtre à l'âge de
8 ans vous avez toujours admiré Pierre
Palmade moi c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a toujours fasciné par
son talent alors comment vous avez fait
pour le rencontrer moi Pierre Palmade
moi je suis monté sur Paris en fait pour
faire carrière dans la mode dans le
mansina d'accord et c'est vrai que je
suis monté j'étais assez jeune et je
connaissais pas grand monde et c'est
vrai que j'ai voulu absolument essayer
de l'approcher essayer de le connaître
mais juste personnellement peut-être pas
avoir des conseils juste d'accord donc
comment vous avez fait pour l'approcher
très simple je suis né à l'air de la
nouvelle technologie c'était par
Instagram vous l'avez laissé un DM tu
vois il a dit quoi je lui ai expliqué
mon cas de figure je vais expliquer en
toute transparence que je venais de
province et que j'étais allé le voir
plus jeune au théâtre et que j'aurais
aimé peut-être changer avec lui tout
simplement et qu'est-ce qui vous a
répondu
tout de suite à l'époque il était déjà
avec quelqu'un en fait et il m'a dit je
ne préfère pas et parce que là vous lui
proposez pas de pouvoir pour proposer
juste de parler et vous lui proposer pas
de mettre avec lui c'est non tout à fait
et si quelqu'un vous demande un moment
je vous rencontrer pour avoir des
conseils moi si quelqu'un m'appelle pour
avoir des conseils je dis pas non je
suis je suis déjà avec quelqu'un il y a
pas de conseils
je suis désolé si mes messages ont pensé
et finalement dès la semaine d'après en
fait il m'a renvoyé un message en me
proposant tout simplement de prendre un
verre d'accord pour le coup très bien
bon ça c'est plutôt cool voilà et donc
là vous prenez un verre avec lui vous
devenez des potes là oui tout de suite
en fait on a parlé comme si qu'on se
connaissait depuis des années alors que
pas du tout
et c'est vrai que que Pierre Palmade il
a vraiment cette générosité c'est
quelqu'un qui est
profondément humain et c'est vrai que on
s'est vu on s'est revu et puis après
c'est vrai qu'on s'est lié plus d'amitié
de il y a une passion qui est née
pendant voilà d'être tombe amoureux de
lui amoureux je dirais pas amoureux mais
on a eu vraiment
quelque chose c'est-à-dire que on
s'entendait très bien on se confiait
l'un à l'autre je savais quand il allait
mal parfois j'avais pas de nouvelles en
effet pendant parce que vous étiez
ensemble ou pas vous étiez votre enfant
mais on se voyait comme si qu'on était
en effet ensemble d'accord on a toujours
gardé cette liberté il aimait aussi
se ressourcer justement dans sa maison à
la campagne est-ce que vous avez fait
déjà fait des soirées comme on en a dans
cette dont on a parlé alors
moi le fait et je ne veux absolument pas
accuser Pierre Palmade côté aussi
conscient de ce que je faisais mais
c'est vrai que
en le côtoyant je suis tombé dans
certains excès c'est quoi les excès
c'est que c'est c'était plus d'alcool
c'était à toucher essayer la cocaïne la
vieille j'avais touché avant avant non
avant jamais et c'est vrai que
avec le temps moi je me suis aperçu que
quand même c'était pas forcément bien je
me suis rendu compte tout de suite
surtout qu'on a eu quelques entre
guillemets mauvais aventures c'est à
dire qu'en effet c'est quelqu'un qui
une fois qu'il avait consommé pas mal de
substances n'étaient plus mettre
forcément de lui-même et ça c'est
quelque chose en effet qui me faisait
peur aussi
donc est-ce que vous avez déjà fait donc
ce genre de soirée avec des
Rocks du sexe oui vous avez tous les
deux vous étiez aussi alors il savait
moi je suis quelqu'un de très pudique
aussi d'accord et il savait que je
n'aimais pas avoir 26000 personnes
autour de moi d'accord donc en effet ça
a été uniquement uniquement nous deux
oui
alors
aujourd'hui quand vous avez entendu ce
qui s'était passé est-ce que vous êtes
dit je me suis est-ce que vous êtes dit
je sais exactement la soirée qu'ils ont
passé avant ce drame alors il faut
savoir que en plus j'étais complètement
déboussolée d'apprendre cela parce que
moi j'étais en week-end à ce moment-là à
la campagne à Combrand donc c'était
clairement pas
la nouvelle dont je m'attendais mais
quand j'ai su cette nouvelle je me suis
pas non plus étonné c'est ça qui est
grave je pense dans
dans cette histoire c'est que moi je
vais toujours dit par contre les mois
qu'on a passé à être intime et proches
je lui dis il faut ralentir parce qu'un
jour ça te tuera
moi je lui ai dit il y a des fois où en
effet il a les mal lui-même et je lui ai
dit et donc c'est vrai que quand j'ai su
cette nouvelle au début je voulais pas y
croire mais je me suis dit c'est pas
impossible et puis après quand il y a
les sites sérieux quand on parlait je me
suis passé une évidence finalement
alors aujourd'hui je sais que vous avez
dit vous trouvez que aujourd'hui à faire
vous dites contre Pierre pas loin alors
moi je le dis de mon point de vue parce
que comme l'a dit Jean-Marie Bigard tout
à l'heure c'est vrai que quand on a
connu une personne
notre jugement il peut être aussi on va
dire un peu altéré on n'a pas forcément
le même jugement après en effet alors
d'aujourd'hui il y a un il y a une
enquête
sur les réseaux sociaux on le sait tous
dès qu'il y a une faute sur
les charges
là si on peut pas parler de fautes là
c'est c'est moi j'ai toujours adoré ici
je l'adore et j'ai comme m'a dit
Benjamin tout à l'heure au téléphone il
y a deux pierres palmates Pierre Palmade
de l'après-midi qui est extraordinaire
un garçon qui peut voilà ce que vous me
disait moi je connais moins bien mais
qui est tout le monde me dit ça qui est
un garçon incroyable c'est des qui est
incroyable qui est drôle
entendu qui veut aider tout le monde qui
est un amour de mec je sais que
j'enverrai tu connais bien aussi et puis
il y a le pire Palma de la nuit le démon
quoi c'est un des c'est des démons
arrivent et là là ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui moi je pense avant tout je
peux vous dire moi je pense pas une
instance un instant à Pierre Palmade je
vous dis la vérité je pense à 100 % à la
famille et je pense à cette date qui a
perdu son enfant et à ce ce petit garçon
de 6 ans qui est entre la vie et la mort
le reste vraiment Pierre Palmade alors
ils sont des sorties très bien mais
aujourd'hui Pierre Palmade je pense pas
une seconde à lui
je pense pas qu'il y a un lynchage
contre Pierre Palmade c'est juste qu'à
un moment moi je veux bien qu'on ait des
fêlures je veux bien qu'on ait des
blessures je veux bien qu'on aille mal
mais un moment quand on met en danger la
vie d'autrui on passe on enlève
qu'on enlève à une mère son enfant qui
allait naître dans deux mois il y a
aucune excuse aucune il y a zéro excuse
je vous le dis voilà on peut on l'aime
bien tous ici mais il y a zéro excuse et
je pense que même lui doit se dire il a
zéro excuse bien sûr Michel non je veux
juste dire que
un gros point d'interrogation c'est
pourquoi alors que le frigo est vide
qu'ils ont faim ça je peux l'entendre
pourquoi ils commandent pas de la
nourriture il y a des systèmes de de
livraison est-ce que est-ce qu'ils sont
pas partis recharger plutôt euh
moi je vous dis la vérité Pierre Palmade
il est chez lui il envoie deux potes
même aller chercher à manger ou un pote
ou bien il commande ce truc mais à un
moment je pense que il a dû se dire on
va aller voilà j'ai fini c'est une
hypothèse on va charger je pense nos
substances ou un truc comme ça et
peut-être qu'il connaissaient des gars
qu'il a dû y aller avec eux je vous dis
à la télé l'hypothèse du supermarché j'y
crois pas un instant je pense pas à un
instant qui soit allé chercher des ou
des mikados excusez-moi de vous dire ça
non mais c'est vrai voilà donc voilà je
vous dis à mon avis il a dû aller
rechercher de la drogue je pense hein
l'hypothèse ça change rien
c'est vraiment le drame il a conduire et
c'est vraiment un c'est un drame juste
Benjamin qui qui Matthieu tous les
réagir 2 secondes je veux dire deux
choses que enfin moi j'ai des trois fois
avec et je me souviens une fois j'avais
dîné avec lui chez Mireille d'humain et
voilà c'était un peu triste et il avait
dit pour rire ça me revient maintenant
je je finis un jour dans la rubrique
fait divers mais je viens de cette
phrase qu'il avait dit à table
effectivement il est il allait déjà très
mal à l'époque et j'étais surpris de
voir tout ça d'après si je peux me
permettre de dire aussi quelque chose
ça n'a rien à voir mais si quand même ça
peut être 32 ans que je suis à Paris en
32 ans je crois que samedi ou dimanche
j'ai été arrêté une fois en 32 ans une
fois la nuit pour le test salivaire ou
pour le test d'alcoolémie une fois en 32
ans donc ça serait peut-être bien aussi
qu'on commence on peut pas on peut pas
tomber sur les policiers
les policiers les pauvres les policiers
ils ont énormément de travail si en plus
ils doivent s'occuper des mecs qui sont
en névrosé et qui prennent de la con qui
est de l'alcool
il est responsable à 100%
là vraiment là c'est un changement
bien sûr et de temps en temps les
contrôles aléatoire mais là c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui
est-ce que tu l'aies au téléphone non
tout simplement parce qu'on a fait dès
qu'il y a eu le souci j'essaie de
l'appeler son téléphone il a été
retrouvé là il y a pas longtemps donc on
a pas réussi à le joindre non j'ai pas
réussi à le joindre tu as essayé de
l'appeler quand même oui quand même ça
j'essaie de l'appeler par contre juste
pour revenir sur une phrase que Mathieu
a dit et ça c'est vrai que c'est très
vrai c'était un clown triste c'est un
clown triste je dis c'était non il est
encore vivant c'est un clone triste mais
moi je vais toujours dit je dis la
drogue et la cocaïne ça te tuera et
quand je disais l'alcool et l'alcool il
me regardait d'ailleurs de dire oui mais
le truc je suis toujours dit aussi un
truc je lui ai dit tu as le droit de
faire ce que tu veux chez toi mais une
fois on était sorti et il était dans un
état